.
Familie Almeida wandert aus.
In 3 Std.
geht der Flieger nach Kanada.
Ja, Schatz.
Am Ende ist es immer schwer.
Aber das gehört zum Abschiednehmen.
Das ist leider so.
Viel Glück.
Im Osten Kanadas
sucht Familie Almeida
aus dem Kanton Zürich die Ruhe.
Sie übernimmt ein altes Motel.
Vom Emmental nach Uruguay.
Ruedi und Susanne Althaus
zieht es nach Südamerika.
Dort bauen sie eigenhändig
eine Ferienlodge.
Und an der Nordsee
eröffnet Familie Kunz einen Imbiss.
Mit Pommes und Currywurst starten
die Baselbieter in ein neues Leben.
# Uf u dervo.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
Das Haus in Läufelfingen
hat Familie Kunz verkauft.
Jetzt gilt es ernst.
Das war die letzte Nacht
in unserem Haus.
Schon in ein paar Wochen
stehen Vater Sacha und Sohn Kevin
gemeinsam hinter dem Grill
im Imbisswagen am Wattenmeer.
So die Idee.
Das ist ein neuer Lebensabschnitt
für uns.
Schön ist,
dass wir als ganze Familie gehen.
Und ...
Ich denke, das ist etwas Schönes.
Zuerst war ich skeptisch:
"Das läuft nicht,
macht es nicht, das ist scheisse."
Das änderte sich mit der Zeit.
Es könnte laufen,
denn es ist ein Touristenmagnet.
(Sacha)
Dort hat es eine Schraube mehr.
Ja, gut.
Stellen wir es nach hinten.
Danke.
Den Umzug an die Nordsee stemmt
die fünfköpfige Familie selbst,
ohne Zügelunternehmen.
Das spart Geld.
Tür auf. Danke schön.
Hast du wirklich
nichts mehr rumliegen?
Nein, ich glaube nicht.
Hier ist jetzt
die Bettwäsche und ...
Grossmutter Susanne
zieht mit in den Norden.
Sie will nach ihren Enkeln
Timo und Noemi schauen,
während die Eltern
im Imbisswagen arbeiten.
Alles weg.
- Was weg?
Das kann nicht hierbleiben.
- Doch.
Jemand sollte da sein.
Denn für die Kinder
ist es etwas schwierig
bei einem Neuaufbau,
wenn die Eltern arbeiten.
Nicht wahr, Timo?
- Ja.
Sie sind ja immer
den ganzen Tag weg.
Schauen wir mal, wie es herauskommt.
Aber auf jeden Fall freue ich mich,
denn man hat auch das Gefühl,
dass man noch gebraucht wird.
Nebenan sortieren Mutter Brigitte
und Tochter Noemi Sportkleidung aus.
Ich nehme an, das behältst du?
- Natürlich.
Das ist von Noemi, als sie
bei den kleinen Cheerleadern war,
den Unicorns.
Es ist ein Erinnerungsstück.
Der Cheerleading-Verein in Basel
war bis jetzt Noemis Ein und Alles.
Es ist ein wenig hart.
Aber ich freue mich
auch auf etwas Neues.
Im Cheerleading werde ich
sicher auch Freunde finden.
Du hast schon welche gefunden.
- Ja, ein paar.
Auf Instagram
habe ich nach ihnen gesucht.
Daraus entstanden Kontakte.
Wir waren zwei Wochen dort.
Sie war schon in fünf Trainings
und hat bei einem Mädchen
schon zweimal übernachtet.
Das läuft.
(Sacha) Kommen wir hier durch?
Warte, jetzt müssen wir ...
(Kevin) Stopp!
- Entschuldigung.
Geht doch!
Nur das Nötigste
kommt mit ins neue Heim.
Hast du es?
- Willst du jetzt hinten raus?
Da, komm! Du musst schieben.
(Lachend) Komm, mach mal!
- Schieb zu mir!
* Knarren *
Macht nichts.
Das alte Sofa jedenfalls bleibt hier.
Die ganze Wohnzimmereinrichtung
wollen sie
in Norddeutschland neu kaufen.
So, rein! Und jetzt noch das Tor.
* Dynamische Musik *
Den verbleibenden Hausrat
bringen sie zu Brigittes Mutter.
Sie wohnt
nur ein paar Hundert Meter weiter.
In ihrem Haus hat es genügend Platz.
Super.
Sind das eure Kleider?
- Ja.
Die kommen ins Zimmer.
Bis zur Abreise in sieben Wochen
kommt die ganze Familie hier unter.
Samt Katze Roxy und Hund Falco.
Guten Appetit.
- Guten Appetit.
Schon zum zweiten Mal.
* Leichte, beschwingte Musik *
In den Ferien am Meer.
Noch sind sie hier nur in den Ferien,
das aber schon zum zehnten Mal.
In ein paar Monaten
werden Ruedi Althaus und seine
Frau Susanne der Schweiz Adieu sagen.
In Uruguay wollen sich die Emmentaler
eine neue Existenz aufbauen.
Unweit des Río de la Plata -
einem Strom,
der bis zum Horizont reicht.
Wunderschön.
Ein langer Strand
und keine Menschen.
Nicht wie in Rimini -
dritte Reihe, der 25. Stuhl.
Nein, man hat einen ganzen Strand
für sich alleine.
Vom menschenleeren Strand ins Zentrum
von Colonia del Sacramento
sind es mit dem Auto nur 10 Min.
Die älteste Stadt Uruguays
ist ein beliebtes Ausflugsziel -
auch bei den
zukünftigen Auswanderern.
* Entspannte südamerikanische Musik *
Momentan sind wir noch Touristen.
Ich fühle mich aber
auch schon ein wenig heimisch.
Denn wir sind
schon einige Male hier gewesen.
Und trotzdem
sind wir immer noch fasziniert.
Was für Ruedi und Susanne
mit Ferien begann,
entwickelte sich
über die letzten drei Jahre
zu einem Projekt
für die zweite Lebenshälfte.
Jetzt treiben sie ihren Traum voran.
Den ersten Termin
haben sie mit Architektin Jimena
und Maklerin Alexandra.
Alles klar?
- Ja. Danke. Selber?
Morgen.
- Morgen.
Alexandra wuchs in Uruguay auf,
ihre Eltern sind Deutsche.
Sie ist bestens vernetzt
und hilft Einwanderern
bei den ersten Schritten.
Im Frühjahr 2016 hatte sie Ruedi
und Susanne ein Stück Land gezeigt,
das die beiden kurzentschlossen
und noch ohne konkreten Plan kauften.
Hat noch jemand einen Schlüssel?
- Eigentlich nicht.
Wir können ja da ...
- Da durch oder ...
Da auf der Seite.
Hier geht's.
Das Grundstück ist 5 ha gross.
Juhu!
So viel wie sieben Fussballfelder.
Unser Stück Land.
- Muy feliz.
Schön.
Unser neues Zuhause.
Einfach noch ohne Haus.
Das kommt noch.
Eines nach dem anderen.
Die beiden wollen eine Posada bauen,
eine Art Ferienlodge
mit fünf Häusern,
Restaurant und Swimmingpool.
Als gelernter Bauschreiner
möchte Ruedi
so viel wie möglich selber machen.
Noch mal einen Nagel einschlagen.
- Gemeinsam etwas machen.
Mal schauen, ob es klappt,
das zusammen zu erschaffen.
- Genau.
Jetzt haben wir
noch Kraft und Energie.
Mit 60 könnte uns für ein so
grosses Projekt die Energie fehlen.
Ja, probieren wir's.
Für das Land haben sie
bereits rund 100'000 Fr. investiert.
Und der Bau der Lodge
kostet sie noch einiges mehr.
Bevor Ruedi und Susanne
nach Uruguay ziehen,
soll Bauunternehmer Mauricio
das Land erschliessen.
Architektin Jimena
hat ihn vermittelt.
(Spanisch)
Verstanden?
- Grösstenteils.
Acá tenemos que mirar,
que acá está el pozo.
Ich habe das Gefühl,
er weiss, worum es geht.
Soweit ich verstehe,
weiss er, wovon er redet.
Er ist vom Fach.
Er sagte auch,
der Termin gehe in Ordnung.
Ob es dann so ist - mal schauen,
wir lassen uns überraschen.
Aber der erste Eindruck von ihm
ist gut.
Der Bauunternehmer
will den beiden so schnell
wie möglich seine Offerte schicken.
* Schreie *
Familie Almeida aus dem Kanton Zürich
nimmt jeden Tag
ein wenig Abschied von der Schweiz.
Schau mal!
Robin, André und Sofie
gehen heute ein letztes Mal
mit ihren Eltern in den Freizeitpark.
Für Familie Almeida
ist die Zeit reif für neue Abenteuer.
Schon in einer Woche geht es los.
Robin, wohin willst du?
Der 46-jährige Josef übernimmt
zusammen mit seiner Frau Beatrice
ein altes Motel
in der kanadischen Provinz.
Sie wünschten sich
einen letzten Besuch hier.
Unser Wunsch war das nicht.
Nein, aber das ist so toll für sie.
Sie haben Spass.
* Dynamische Countrymusik *
Almeidas waren vor zwei Jahren
zum ersten Mal in Kanada.
Es gefiel ihnen gleich so gut,
dass sie sich spontan
ein Ferienhaus kauften.
Seitdem liess sie das Land
nicht mehr los.
Ich freue mich irrsinnig.
Wenn ich darüber nachdenke
und es mir bewusst wird,
dann freue ich mich wirklich sehr.
Aber ich habe noch nicht realisiert,
dass ich vieles hinter mir lasse,
viele gute Freunde
und ganz tolle Beziehungen,
die ich eigentlich aufgebe.
Das wird wahrscheinlich noch kommen.
Etwas Neues wagen und das Leben
noch einmal anders ausrichten:
An dieser Idee
fand auch die 41-jährige Beatrice
nach und nach Gefallen.
Seit zehn Jahren hält die beiden ihr
Bed and Breakfast ständig auf Trab.
Wir möchten etwas zurück
und es mehr geniessen.
Das ist es eigentlich,
was ich mir sehr wünsche.
Denn wenn man viel arbeitet,
denkt man, man verpasse auch viel.
Und auch für sich, dass man ...
... mehr zur Ruhe kommt.
Ich hoffe inständig,
dass das dort besser wird.
Wir arbeiten immer zu viel.
Ruhe und mehr Zeit mit den Kindern,
das erhoffen sich Almeidas in Kanada.
Eins, zwei, drei!
Ja! Ja!
* Jubel *
Woah!
André, du warst am langsamsten.
Ich glaube, du bist zu leicht.
Läufelfingen im Baselbiet.
Bis zur Abreise nach Norddeutschland
wohnt Familie Kunz
bei Brigittes Mutter Susanne.
Hoi.
Ich bereite gerade
das letzte Training vor.
Seinen Job im Aussendienst
hat Sacha schon aufgegeben.
Zum Saisonende gibt er auch
seinen Posten als Fussballtrainer ab.
Jetzt geht's dem Ende zu.
- Bald ist vorbei mit Fussball.
Hast du nachher noch einen Match?
- Nein. Es ist fertig.
Jetzt geht's vorwärts.
Du kannst schon bald
die Stunden zählen.
Ich zähle schon die Tage.
Das machst du schon lange.
- Eben, ja.
Zum letzten Mal
packe ich meine Fussballtasche.
Für den FC Härkingen.
Zweimal pro Woche trainiert der
50-Jährige eine Juniorenmannschaft.
* Lautes Quietschen *
Sohn Timo nimmt er immer mit.
* Wehmütige Akkordeonmusik *
In Läufelfingen
fühlte sich Sacha eigentlich wohl.
Er hatte für die Familie
ein schönes Haus,
hatte Freunde und war
in Fussballerkreisen geschätzt.
Nur sein Job als Vertreter
machte ihm zunehmend Kopfzerbrechen.
Wir lassen sehr viel zurück.
Es wird uns sicherlich
nicht so einfach fallen.
Aber aufgrund der letzten ...
Es war nicht nur das letzte Jahr,
das beruflich nicht so toll war.
Die letzten Jahre im Detailhandel
in der Schweiz waren ein Kampf.
Nun hat sich
diese Gelegenheit ergeben,
und wir freuen uns darauf.
50'000 km fuhr Sacha pro Jahr,
hetzte von Kunde zu Kunde.
An der Nordsee wird er von Frühling
bis Herbst an der Fritteuse stehen.
Im neuen Job habe ich auch
einen gewissen Umsatzdruck.
Wir arbeiten acht Monate,
und die acht Monate müssen laufen.
Sonst müssen wir schauen,
wie wir über den Winter kommen.
* Wehmütige Akkordeonmusik *
Das Leibchen noch anziehen.
Hoi.
- Hoi.
Schau mal auf den Boden!
Die müssen nicht
auf dem Boden liegen.
Anfangen, kommt!
Zwei Ballberührungen, denkt daran.
Die Liebe zum Fussball wurde Sacha
bereits in die Wiege gelegt.
Sein Vater war Profi beim FC Basel,
der Grossvater
ein bekannter Schiedsrichter.
Sacha selbst war jahrelang Torhüter
und danach Trainer.
Es wird mir sicher fehlen,
aber ich habe mich entschieden.
Ich werde mich auch
entsprechend einstellen müssen.
Aber auch dort gibt es Fussball.
Es wird vielleicht
auch dort eine Tür aufgehen,
sodass ich eine Juniorenmannschaft
führen kann.
Noch eine Minute, kommt!
Das war gut, Ramon.
* Schlusspfiff *
Jenen, die ich nicht mehr sehe,
wünsche ich alles Gute.
Es liegt mir am Herzen,
dass ihr weitermacht.
Dass wir das Jahr,
in dem wir etwas aufgebaut haben,
nicht wegschmeissen,
sondern weiterführen.
Egal, in welcher Mannschaft.
* Jubelschrei *
Das ist okay. Es ist ja warm.
Das ist kein Problem.
* Wehmütige Akkordeonmusik *
Das neue Leben in Norddeutschland
ist für Sacha und seine Familie
schon zum Greifen nah.
* Muhen *
Nächster Termin in Uruguay.
Architektin Jimena hat die Skizzen,
die Ruedi von der Posada
gezeichnet hat, überarbeitet.
Ah! Ta-ta-ta-ta-tam.
Ta-tam. Aha.
Erste Änderungen hat Jimena
am Restaurant und der Rezeption
vorgenommen.
Sie schlägt vor,
dort Glastüren einzubauen.
Du kannst
keine kleinen Fenster machen.
Das wirkt nicht einladend.
Der Gast sitzt da
und kann durch dieses kleine Fenster
nicht richtig rausgucken.
Hat man Fenstertüren bis unten,
muss man die Sessel und so
etwas weiter entfernt hinstellen.
Das sieht scheisse aus.
Geht nicht.
- Geht nicht.
Die Sessel
kann man nach vorne ziehen.
Nein, das bleibt so.
Ruedi weiss, wie man baut.
Aber den Stil der Gebäude
überlässt er den Frauen.
Da hat man verloren,
bevor man begonnen hat.
Nein, nein. Das ist gut.
Das soll so sein.
Es ist nicht ganz einfach.
Am Schluss
muss das Resultat stimmen.
Unterschiedliche Meinungen sind gut,
deshalb sitzen wir zusammen.
Wir bewahren ihn
vor grossen Fehlern.
Obwohl ich immer
sehr praktisch denke -
er denkt noch praktischer.
Aber manchmal
ist die Ästhetik wichtig.
Gut, machen wir gross.
* Alexandra lacht. *
Die schwerste Geburt
ist jetzt hinter uns, oder?
* Entspannte südamerikanische Musik *
Die Weite, die Ruhe und die Menschen
haben es Susanne und Ruedi angetan.
Aber nicht nur für sie ist Uruguay
das vermeintliche Paradies.
Auch andere Schweizer
hat es hierher verschlagen.
Die Umgebung hier
wurde von Schweizern aufgebaut.
Schweizer,
die hierher ausgewandert sind,
haben das Paraíso Suizo aufgebaut.
Irgendein Schweizer
hat hier Land gekauft
und es nachher
an andere Schweizer weiterverkauft.
Jemand zu Hause?
- Der Bock ist da.
Hallo! Hallo!
- So, ihr ...
Die Bündner René und Sonja Tobler
sind da,
wo Ruedi und Susanne noch hinwollen.
Seit über 20 Jahren
betreiben sie ein kleines Gästehaus.
Guten Appetit.
- Guten Appetit. Danke.
Zum Wohl.
- Zum Wohl. Danke vielmals.
Seine Erfahrungen vom Leben
in der südamerikanischen Pampa
teilt René gerne.
Anders ist: Im Winter ist hier
die Luftfeuchtigkeit relativ hoch.
Deshalb, Ruedi,
sollte man gut isolieren.
Oh ja.
- Denk daran. Das ist so.
Ich isoliere nicht so
wie die in Uruguay.
* Leichte, beschwingte Musik *
6.30 Uhr in der Früh.
Gut geschlafen?
- Ja. - Also, kommt.
Robin, willst du ein Joghurt?
Noch ist Alltag
in der Casa Almeida in Turbenthal.
Schoko?
- Ja, gerne.
Beatrice übernimmt die Kinder.
Ehemann Josef
bereitet mit Grossmutter Tina
das Frühstück für die Gäste vor.
(Portugiesisch)
Kann ich das wegräumen?
- Ja.
Bis zu zwölf Gäste
können Josef und Beatrice in
ihrem Bed and Breakfast beherbergen.
Ja, dein Teig. Genau.
Es ist immer
relativ hektisch am Morgen.
Bis die Kinder aus dem Haus sind ...
Und dann kommen die Gäste.
Man muss schon einige Male
rauf- und runtergehen.
Wir sind immer etwas auf Zack,
sagen wir's so.
Tina ist am Vortag mit
ihrem Lebenspartner hier eingezogen.
Sie ist pensioniert
und wird nach der Abreise der Familie
den Gästebetrieb übernehmen.
Hier sind die Cerealien.
Gib ihm ...
Cerealien, Honig, Brotaufstrich.
Schokolade für die Milch.
Möchte jemand von euch
ein gekochtes Ei?
Sehr gerne.
- Auch? Zwei.
5 Min.?
- Ja.
Zwei Eier?
- Bitte gerne zwei Eier.
Die sind von den eigenen Hühnern.
Eins reicht trotzdem. Gut, also.
Wie viele?
- Drei.
Trotz neuer Aufgabe:
Es fällt Tina schwer,
die Familie ziehen zu lassen.
Es ist traurig. Sie gehen
mit den Enkelkindern und allem.
Aber so ist das Leben.
Ich bin auch weg von meinen Eltern
und in die Schweiz gegangen.
Das muss ich akzeptieren.
Bis sie in Kanada
heimisch geworden sind,
wollen die Almeidas
das Bed and Breakfast noch behalten.
Papi?
- Hier bin ich.
Man hat immer das Gefühl:
"Es dauert noch zwei Monate,
noch einen Monat, drei Wochen ..."
Und heute in einer Woche
sitzen wir schon im Flieger.
Das ist sehr speziell.
Es kommen Gedanken auf wie:
"Das letzte Mal dies, das letzte Mal
den Müll rausbringen."
Es ist sehr komisch.
Tschüss, Oma.
- Tschau.
* Leichte, beschwingte Musik *
Wattenmeer, Krabbenkutter
und Strandkörbe.
Dazu nicht selten eine steife Brise.
* Sehnsüchtige Akkordeonmusik *
Für viele Auswanderer
wäre die raue Nordsee das Letzte,
was sie sich vorstellen könnten.
Und Sonnenschein.
Kein Regen,
die Temperatur stimmt auch ...
Das ist super, oder?
- Tipptopp.
Schon seit Jahren
verbringen wir hier unsere Ferien.
Es hat uns schon immer gefallen.
Wir sagten schon immer, dass wir
irgendwann hierherziehen würden.
Und jetzt hat sich
die Gelegenheit ergeben,
und wir haben sie genutzt.
Das ist dort drüben, nicht?
- Ja.
Die Baselbieter haben drei Tage Zeit,
um in Norddeutschland alles
für das neue Leben vorzubereiten.
Dafür hat sich Brigitte
extra freigenommen.
Noch arbeitet sie Teilzeit als
Verkäuferin in einem Sportgeschäft.
Moin.
- Hallo.
Zweimal Currywurst.
Mit Pommes oder ohne?
- Ohne.
Man macht sich seine Gedanken,
wenn man sich
verschiedene Imbisswagen anschaut.
Man versetzt sich dann schon fast
ins eigene Geschäft hinein.
Man vergleicht und schaut,
was die anderen anbieten.
Das ist eigentlich noch spannend.
* Rattern *
Ich habe schon einmal.
- Super.
Sieben Tage in der Woche werden
Sacha und Brigitte während der Saison
hinter dem Verkaufstresen stehen.
Diese Vorstellung aber
schreckt sie nicht.
Obwohl sie bisher
kaum Gastronomieerfahrung haben.
Die ist nicht schlecht.
- Ja, die ist gut, wirklich gut.
Die schmeckt ...
Auch die Sauce ist sehr gut.
Auf die Sauce kommt es an, nicht?
Das ist eigentlich ... Ja.
Das ist noch wichtig.
* Gemächliche Tubaklänge *
Frisch gestärkt geht's zum Möbelkauf.
Mega Store.
- Mega Store.
Mal schauen, wie das Ledersofa ist.
Das ist
so ein richtig altes Opasofa.
Okay. Okay.
Auch nicht so schlecht, oder?
Ist gut mit der Lehne?
Nicht so wie ...
Nach den langen Arbeitstagen
im Imbisswagen
wollen sie auf ein bequemes Sofa
nicht verzichten.
Eigentlich überlasse ich es ihr,
aber letztlich ...
Er denkt wohl:
"Hauptsache, wir haben ein Sofa."
So schnell wie möglich eines kaufen
und wieder raus.
Nein, in der Regel schauen wir es
gemeinsam an. - Eigentlich schon.
Aber ihr Geschmack ist ...
na ja ... der ist okay.
Wie ist er?
- Er ist okay.
Wie ist mein Geschmack?
- Ja, ja ...
Du suchst ja jeweils aus und ...
Willst du es nicht einfach
in Schwarz nehmen? So wie hier?
Wie ist es mit der Lieferfrist,
wenn man einen anderen Stoff nimmt?
Acht bis zwölf Wochen.
Eine andere Farbe
kostet einen Aufpreis.
Wie viele Wochen?
- Acht bis zwölf Wochen.
Okay, funktioniert nicht.
Wie lange dauert es
mit einem Sofa von hier?
Wir können nicht so lange warten.
Für gewöhnlich dauert es 14-15 Tage.
In fünf Wochen
brauchen wir ein Sofa.
Wir sind etwas spät dran.
Ach nein. Das klappt schon.
Beide wären vorrätig.
Die Farbe ist nicht so schlecht.
- Nein, ist okay.
Es ist auch am Lager, es ist okay.
- Ja, das ist schon gut.
Ja, es ist okay. Liefert ihr?
- Wir liefern auch.
Sofa gut, alles gut.
In Turbenthal in der Casa Almeida
haben die Gäste ausgecheckt.
Guetzli - ja, genau.
Die mögen die Leute.
Josef zeigt seiner Mutter Tina, auf
was sie zukünftig alles achten muss.
Die Arbeit im Bed and Breakfast
ist für Tina nicht wirklich neu.
Sie hatte ihren Sohn während der
Ferien schon ein paarmal vertreten.
Beatrice
backt unterdessen 300 Anisguetzli,
ein letzter Auftrag
für eine Kirchengemeinde.
Die Produktion des Süssgebäcks
ist das zweite Standbein von Familie
Almeida, neben dem Gästebetrieb.
Man ist schon etwas wehmütig.
Wir haben es aufgebaut,
unsere ganze Energie reingesteckt,
all unsere Mittel.
Wüssten wir nicht,
dass es in guten Händen ist,
würden wir es wohl nicht machen.
Ganz loslassen
kann Beatrice aber noch nicht.
Im Herbst will sie für einige Wochen
wieder in ihre Backstube zurückkehren
und die Guetzli
auf verschiedenen Märkten verkaufen.
Betten beziehen, Zimmer putzen,
waschen - jeden Tag aufs Neue.
Ich habe das jetzt
fast zehn Jahre gemacht.
In den ersten Jahren
hatte ich gar keine Ferien.
Ich arbeitete an den Wochenenden
und an den Feiertagen.
Das wird in Kanada schon anders
mit den Angestellten.
Es ist anstrengend,
auf Dauer kräfteraubend.
Ich möchte mehr Zeit
mit meinen Kindern verbringen.
Es muss wirklich perfekt sein.
Das ist mir schon wichtig.
Da zeigt sich der Schweizer,
der assimilierte Schweizer.
Oh-oh, Joca.
Da braucht es noch ein Bett.
Hier schläft
zusätzlich noch ein Kind.
Zwischen einem und vier Betten
können Gäste buchen - je nach Zimmer.
Da bekommt auch ein Kind.
Sie hat sich verguckt.
Hier sind drei Personen, nicht dort.
Aber das ist kein Problem.
Das sind 2 Min. Arbeit,
das ist nicht so schlimm.
Sie ist da noch nicht so sattelfest.
Und es ist ganz wichtig,
dass man ...
... dass man das auch richtig macht.
Dieses Zimmer hat ein privates Bad
und jenes nebenan nicht.
Die Leute buchen das,
und werden dann negativ überrascht.
Es gab deswegen
auch schon schlechte Bewertungen.
In Kanada ist das anders,
dort sind alle Zimmer einheitlich.
Das ist ein Vorteil.
In einer Woche
muss Tina alleine klarkommen.
Josef bleibt nicht mehr viel Zeit,
seine Mutter vollends ins Geschäft
mit den Gästen einzuführen.
* Schiffshorn *
Der Blick aufs Wattenmeer
gehört für Sacha und Brigitte
bald zum Arbeitsalltag.
Denn direkt am Kutterhafen
steht ein Imbisswagen,
den die Baselbieter
übernehmen wollen.
Nach Dorum, einer Ortschaft
mit rund 3'500 Einwohnern,
sind es nur ein paar Kilometer.
Hier haben sich Sacha und Brigitte
ein günstiges Haus mit drei Wohnungen
gekauft.
Zwei Jahre stand es leer.
Wo legen wir los?
Wolltest du nochmals
die Leisten anschauen? - Ja.
Das ist nicht schön gemacht.
Das müssen wir mit dem Schreiner
nochmals anschauen.
Nach dem Kauf
haben sie das Haus selbst renoviert,
alte Möbel entsorgt, Tapeten abgelöst
und die Wände neu gestrichen.
Den Backofen
müssen wir noch entsorgen.
Für Böden und Bäder
haben sie Handwerker beauftragt.
Ich glaube, der ist nicht neu.
- Er müsste aber neu sein.
Das Bad
entpuppte sich als grosse Baustelle.
Hier drin hatten wir
einen relativ grossen Wasserschaden.
Die Decke hing herunter.
Oben war ein Rohrbruch.
Es war wirklich nass.
Aber ein guter Nachbar
hat uns dabei sehr geholfen.
Er hat quasi
die Bauleitung übernommen
und hat das Ganze hier koordiniert.
Er hat das super gemacht.
Ein Glücksfall,
denn ohne die Hilfe des Nachbarn
wäre die Wohnung
längst noch nicht fertig.
Ist offen?
- Es sollte offen sein.
Einen Stock höher
sind zwei weitere Wohnungen.
Sohn Kevin
soll das kleine Appartement beziehen.
Hier oben war es schlimm.
Aber unser grosser Sohn
richtet die Wohnung dann selber her,
darum haben wir sie so gelassen.
Das kommt dann auch weg.
- Eine schöne 70er-Jahre-Tapete.
Aber das soll unser Grosser
dann im Winter selber machen.
Das müssen die dann
alles noch hinein machen.
Die grosse Wohnung nebenan
haben sie für Brigittes
Mutter Susanne hergerichtet.
Sie kommt mit nach Dorum.
Wir sind sehr froh, auch wenn unsere
Kinder nicht mehr so klein sind.
Sie können in den Bus steigen
und an den Deich fahren.
Es wäre kein Problem,
aber so ist es besser. Viel besser.
* Gemächliche Musik *
Jetzt folgt noch die Reinigung.
Dann haben wir es geschafft.
* Lebhafte Musik *
Bald ist alles bereit für den Einzug.
Fehlt nur noch das Abschiedsfest,
dann hält Sacha und Brigitte
nichts mehr in der Schweiz.
In Uruguay
wollen Ruedi und Susanne erkunden,
woher sie das Baumaterial
für ihre Posada bekommen.
René Tobler soll übersetzen.
Der 53-jährige Ruedi hat zu Hause im
Emmental bereits eine Liste erstellt,
mit allem, was er zum Bauen braucht.
Ich organisiere das Material.
Mal schauen,
ob es Spezialschrauben gibt.
Jene, die ich gerne hätte.
Das ist die Voraussetzung,
um entsprechend vorzubereiten.
Anderthalb Jahre geben sie sich Zeit.
Dann müssen sie
erste Gäste beherbergen.
* Entspannte Musik *
Wenn es dann mit dem Vermieten
nicht klappt ...
... jonglieren wir auf der Kreuzung.
Einige sind sehr lustig.
Viele müssen noch üben.
Aber das ist mir lieber,
als wenn sie stehlen gehen.
* Entspannte Musik *
Erster Stopp: ein Eisenwarenladen.
Ruedi
möchte ganz bestimmte Schrauben.
Hola, buen día.
- Hola, buen día.
Was es hier nicht gibt,
müssten die Auswanderer im Container
aus der Schweiz mitbringen.
Von der Länge her 10-12 cm,
wenn möglich
ein noch grösserer Durchmesser.
Diez a doce, más o menos.
Weltklasse.
- Perfecto, perfecto.
Este tiene doce.
- Doce.
Genau die brauche ich.
Was kosten sie?
1'760.
Pesos.
No Euro.
Sonst müssten wir
das Projekt abbrechen.
Muy amable. Gracias.
- Gracias. Chao. Gracias.
Adiós.
* Lebhafte Musik *
Weiter geht's zum Sägewerk.
Ich bin hier im Paradies.
Sie suchen Holz für die Decke
der fünf Gästehäuser.
90 mm para la pared.
Es hat Struktur.
Es wäre gut.
- Ich finde es schön.
Ja.
Frau Althaus hat entschieden.
Okay, der Chef sagte Ja.
Nicht wahr, Chef? - Jawohl.
Ich bin gerne Chef.
Ruedi
hat die Holzverarbeitung im Blut.
Er wuchs
in einem Schreinerbetrieb auf,
den einst sein Grossvater
gegründet hatte.
Damit kann man
zwei, drei Häuschen bauen.
Die beiden
sind einen grossen Schritt weiter.
In gut vier Monaten
wollen sie mit dem Bau beginnen.
Nach einer kurzen Nacht
ist es in Turbenthal so weit.
In 3 Std.
geht der Flieger nach Kanada.
Ich packe noch die letzten Sachen.
Almeidas
nehmen so wenig wie möglich mit.
Die wichtigsten Dinge
haben sie in 14 Koffer gepackt
oder bereits per Post
nach Kanada verschickt.
Wir wecken sie ganz sanft.
- Du bist fies.
Hallo. Hallo zusammen.
Jungs.
So.
Es ist Zeit, aufzustehen.
Wir müssen zum Flughafen.
Komm jetzt!
- Ich bin noch müde.
Ja, ich weiss.
Aber du kannst noch im Flieger
oder auf dem Weg dorthin schlafen.
Ich weiss, das ist mühsam.
Schon halb vier.
Ja, jetzt wird uns bewusst ...
... dass wir bald weg sind.
Nicht wahr?
Grossmutter Tina bereitet Sandwiches
für die lange Reise vor.
Gleich muss sie ihren Enkeln
goodbye sagen.
Ja, Schatz.
Bist du gerade traurig?
* Ruhige,
leicht melancholische Klavierklänge *
Am Ende ist es immer schwer.
Aber das gehört zum Abschiednehmen.
Das ist leider so.
Es gibt nicht immer nur Gutes im
Stil von: "Yeah, toll, gehen wir!"
Es tut auch etwas weh.
* Ruhige,
leicht melancholische Klavierklänge *
Über 5'000 km sind es bis Halifax.
Alles Gute.
- Danke gleichfalls.
Danke.
Macht's gut.
Noch einmal ganz fest drücken.
Fast 24 Std. wird die Familie
nach Kanada unterwegs sein.
Ciao.
Viel Glück!
(Beatrice) Tschüss! Danke schön.
* Ruhige,
leicht melancholische Klavierklänge *
In der nächsten Folge:
Ruedi und Susanne sind zurück
im Emmental und räumen ihr Haus.
Wir geben viel auf:
das Geregelte, die Sicherheit.
Sie müssen Abschied nehmen
von ihren drei Söhnen.
Solche Events
werde ich sicher vermissen.
Sacha und Brigitte brechen mit Sack
und Pack nach Norddeutschland auf.
Der Imbisswagen am Kutterhafen
wartet auf die neuen Besitzer
aus der Schweiz.
Nicht mehr Ferien, sondern arbeiten.
Und: Motelbesichtigung in Kanada.
Beatrice beschleichen leise Zweifel.
Da ist ein Riss im Dach.
Es ist ein bisschen
wie eine Wundertüte.
Es ist kein Hilton, Schatz!
# U si stige i Flüger, flüge
mit de Vögu furt, chöme nüme hei.
# U si löh hie aues zrugg
uf dr Suechi für es neus Dahei.
# Si gö hüt no uf u dervo.
# Uf u dervo.
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Philipp Schlatter - 2019